so can you tell me a time that you
showed leadership skills yes of course
uh in my previous job I took the
initiative to expand our clientele to
Asia built my own business Dev sub team
which allowed us to double Revenue
within six months great that's awesome
um now tell it again
but in Reverse wait what why like what
does that have to do we never reversed
the story before I mean it's a pretty
standard interview question yeah I mean
I I really don't understand how that's
related to my job or how that's related
to the day-to-day work that I'd be to
our [ __ ] um okay uh six months uh
within Revenue uh doubled uh built my
sub team expanded clientele to Asia I
took initiative
great yeah now say it again but more
efficiently using only five words
Revenue double Asia initiative
the awesome yeah no that's a good start
but do you think you can do better
do you think the way you told your story
was the most optimal
can you do it without seeing a single
word
ah not a single word think about your
word efficiency
it's great that's exactly what I was
looking for you got it right
you didn't really explain your process
and how you came up with your answer so
unfortunately
you won't be proceeding to the next
round
yeah but but thanks for coming though I
really appreciate it